it was a tough break tough play
um it's a give read we have a chance
for a big play and i believe it at that
um
certainly he works his butt off like all
you know it's just more of a technique
thing so if we have to look at how much
but
um that that was
we just stopped him on the fourth down
play
and uh and so we got the ball
in real good field position we have a
chance to to make some
make something of it and unfortunately
we didn't
that's sean sean payton talking about
taysom hill after last night's game and
it really was a critical moment
when taysom hill had his fumble the
momentum had swung dramatically in new
orleans favor
after a horrendous spot on a fourth and
short
play by the packers was corrected by
replay review
and the saints had the ball they gained
seven yards on first down second and
three it's a read option play and what
happened was that darius smith
he he he delayed his commitment long
enough to freak out taysom hill
and to bait hill into not handing off
and then zadaria smith went straight at
taysom hill and if
and if smith had committed to pursuing
latavius murray
that would have been a huge play because
josh hill who was lined up in the
backfield ran right by zadaria smith to
do some lead blocking they had a convoy
set up
all that tasty mill had to do was get
past darius smith and and he would have
gained
20 25 30 yards or more but it wasn't to
be but that
that has become the main focal point for
all the
taysom hill truthers out there that
think he's not very good
i think the reality is they're
deliberately not using him as much as
they used to because they're trying to
develop him as a quarterback i don't
think that i know that
when you look at his reps especially
special teams dramatically plummeted
his participation in the offense has
dropped repeatedly each week from
almost what 40 percent i think it was in
the playoff game against the vikings or
at least between 30 and 40 and it's in
the 20s and it's getting lower and lower
i think they're just working on getting
him ready to play quarterback next year
if drew brees retires
and as a result when he's on the field
he really isn't doing all that much this
year shireen
and then when you're on the field and
you get a chance to run the ball and you
fumble it makes it look even worse
yeah it sure does 44 offensive snaps
this season that's 23
22 special team snap that's 24 percent
he played 13 of 61 snaps
yesterday and you know to me that's not
enough for taysom hill in this offense i
just think he's special with what he can
do with the ball in his hands he's had
nine total touches and thrown
one pass and at some point they're going
to have to take the bubble wrap off of
him
and let him play i would think if they
want to do
what they have pushed all their poker
chips into the middle of the table for
and that's to
to win a super bowl for drew brees
before he retires and i think we're
seeing the end of drew brees career and
i think it's time and i think you're
going to have to play taysom hill and
get him ready for 2021 at the same time
but try to do that but if
he he's got to become a bigger part of
this offense if if they're going to
succeed
and i know not having michael thomas i
get all that he's special he's one of
the top receivers in the league
obviously set the nfl record last year
with 149 catches we know what he can do
we know how much they miss him
but because they miss him i think you
need to get taysom hill more involved
yeah and see that's the balance if you
are focused on developing him as a
quarterback
how much time are you spending at
practice on that
how much time at practice are you
spending on the plays where taysom hill
is part of your offense i mean they're
still
using him on offense but not like they
did in the past and it really does make
me wonder when i see
two carries yesterday for six yards
including obviously the play with the
fumble
one catch no pass attempts he's got one
pass attempt for the year and it was
completed for a 38-yard gain
in garbage time of the win over the
tampa bay buccaneers
i i just i i feel like that
that there's a sensitivity to drew brees
that is at play here with all the talk
about him not being able to throw the
ball down the field i think at some
level there's a concern that they are
upstaging drew brees and that they are
sticking a knife in the wound and
twisting a little bit by displaying
the the deep ball uh power that that
taysom hill has otherwise because you do
need to use it you've got to keep
defenses honest
in order to manipulate your offense the
way they do with the short passes in the
running game
and if drew brees isn't going to throw
the ball deep down the field then taysom
hill needs to throw the ball deep down
the field once in a while
just to make sure that they don't crowd
the short zones and and eventually
someone's going to do it once they
realize they're just not going to throw
the ball down the field
they're going to bring the safeties up
and they're going to try to take all of
that stuff away maybe that's when they
they do the rope-a-dope and start
throwing the ball down the field or
letting he'll do it but
it's just confusing to me it's an
awkward spot to be in
when they've spent so much money on hill
and when it's becoming clear
that it's a down payment on the future
not a representation that they're going
to take what he did in the playoffs
and expand it dramatically and and the
fact that he's not involved in special
teams to the extent that he was he's
gone from 84
against the vikings in the playoff game
to 16
yesterday they're using him dramatically
less in special teams which tells me
that this is about developing him as a
quarterback but you know if you're not
winning games
and he's not involved it's almost like
the odell beckham
dynamic a little bit well if you
involved this guy a little bit more
maybe you'd be winning games
because you're not winning games with
him being involved on a limited basis so
i i don't know i don't know what they
need to do
uh but the question is going to be there
as long as they're both losing
and we're not seeing much of taysom hill
yeah absolutely and and they need to get
him involved he's such a big part of
that offense or can be such a big part
as you repeatedly have said in that
playoff game last year he was a best
player on the field
he can be the best player on the field
anytime he's on the field if you let him
do what he's capable of doing
yeah i agree with you completely and
it's not like he's slower
it's not like he's got less skill than
he had last year
it's just he needs to have the ball in
his hands in order to show what he can
do but it doesn't help
when you do get an opportunity that you
fumble the football
but you know the packers played that
read option extremely well and that's
how it worked out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports